my talk is titled visualizations in
graph theory and the Wolfram language
it's a mouthful so my name is Michael
Saleh me I am thank you for coming
I'm here from Cambridge Massachusetts so
we're gonna computer vision startup
what's that
zoom I can't zoom look harder it's
called did our labs so basically we do
turnkey cloud deployed computer vision
as a service api's and there we are
right next to massachusetts passages SEO
technology and let me talk a little bit
about ditto at the end but just a
shameless plug I'll be giving out API
keys after the talk so if you're
interested in computer vision just come
talk to me so what I'm really here to
talk to you about is a bit of graph
theory and then mostly about
visualization and so I want to start
with a big question what is the future
of scientific and educational
computation communication so how can we
how can we build a new world of
interactive educational apps what
further medium can we imagine where does
Mathematica fit in what would the
archive look like in 2025 user
interesting questions and the
incomparable Bret Victor answered them
at least in part for parts of graph
theory in about five years ago by
rewriting or rather redesigning an
academic paper as an interactive
document of sequential art so what does
that look like
looks like this so he rewrote watts and
Strogatz his nature paper on network
theory and he added a small amount of
lightweight interactivity in the form of
these hover hover sliders but basically
in describing the the algorithm of the
paper he intertwined pictures and
dynamic infographics and and prose and
really I think that this is this is
really this is a model for the way
things should be so instead of trying to
compress the the author's ideas in their
head through some very low bandwidth
channel of a stream of text you can have
something like this where you can really
see what was in their head and the
potential of this this form I think is
to explain difficult difficult concepts
is unmatched and very very much
underused so if you haven't heard of a
Brett Victor you should check them out
very very cool guy so I just wanted to
start by giving a few motivational
examples about what I consider to be
high-caliber info and data vis apps the
first one is called cascade this is yeah
again five years old the New York Times
they built this interactive app to model
conversations that stem from published
articles and basically what you're
seeing here is is is a model of how
people are talking about a specific
article and you can visualize all the
conversations that stem from a single
tweet over a certain amount of time and
you can see in 3d the conversational
architecture you can infer it's much
easier to do that in 3d
you can see you know the offshoots of
the conversations and whatnot
I think this is really really cool app
it's ahead of its time the second
example is something that I walk past
every day on my way to work it's the
internet observatory at Akamai
headquarters in Cambridge visualizes the
entire internet and what you're seeing
here is a co-current graph of carding
sites from Open DNS following the target
breach of 2014 you can see all these DNS
queries over over a few hours after the
the release of the data so I have
friends at this company called
athenahealth and they have a really
strong visualization group and basically
this shows an interplay of about roughly
10 million data points transactions of
patients metadata during the course of
only 24 hours each mewling dot here is a
single patient and what's happening is
when a patient seeks care they're their
dot moves from their home which is
orange up there to their doctor's office
which is purple then to the referral
networks which is blue and and then
finally converges to the payers for
reimbursement in green again this is all
updated live from their data sources of
all the PCPs around the country the
final example which is something I think
looks really cool so from the center of
complex network research came this
beautiful visualization where they
generated a cosmic web all that means is
they were visualizing galactic super
structures by connecting discrete
galaxies with their nearest neighbors
she was SETI cosmic inflation and this
is all again completely interactable
zoomable
in a web app so basically all of these
examples they're really well-designed
data visible and you compare these
examples with what's currently possible
in the Wolfram cloud you'll see that we
still have a long ways to go my favorite
piece of Wolfram code ever written was
an idea that I shared with Vitaly and he
rewrote my idea is much more elegantly
and it looks like this so you're flying
through a graph all the dynamics have
been optimized so that's cool but it
freezes the front-end it's not
deployable the frame rates are low it's
not interactive etc so we really do have
a long way to go to get to what the
examples that I showed you before so and
the sad thing is is that it's really
easy to do that kind of thing in
Mathematica it's just hard to deploy and
that's something that I was able to sort
of overcome the obstacle of deployment
and I want to talk to you about that so
you know if you can't go with an you
know a ponderous plugin CDF or a you
know a beta online system that it's just
not there yet
well what can you do to overcome these
obstacles I'm going to show you so
before we do that I'm going to give you
a little bit of a backstory on why I'm
interested in in any of this so it's
kind of a funny funny story so I was
contacted by a mathematician from the
University of Chicago in the spring
named Lotso but by his friends come lacy
so lacy he joined the University of
Chicago in 1987 the computer science
department
he's one that gödel the girdle prize in
the donald knuth fries and he's a member
of the National Academy of Sciences so
lacy he announced a really novel
algorithm his graph isomorphism
algorithm
last year on November 10th and how I got
involved with this is well I was doing
contract work for a technical magazine
and helped with the publishing of an
article on his algorithm and they
referred me to him and that's how we met
and since then I've helped him with a
number of things including developing
lecture material phrase his world tour
specifically his talks at the Institute
for Advanced Study and other educational
initiatives around the world so I
wouldn't dare try to go through his
90-minute lectures slides that we've
built in the remaining 15 minutes but I
would definitely encourage you to get
his article and or watch the talks so
quick summary of the result you have to
understand what isomorphism is first you
all know what graphs are computer
scientists use the word graph to just to
refer to a network of of knows with
edges connecting them and Gi graph
isomorphism it's it's a problem decision
problem that's really easy to state but
tricky to solve it it just asks our two
graphs really identical are they really
the same graph in disguise and what does
that mean formally it means that if
there's a one-to-one correspondence
between their nodes such that it
preserves the way the nodes are
connected and here you have an example
of Peterson graph these are all the
Peterson graph they're just different
embeddings so certain pattern
recognition problems are readily mapped
onto graph or sub graph isomorphism
detection it's like the structure of
chemicals if you're looking up trying to
identify some molecules in a structure
database you'll basically you're looking
for a particular functional group that's
just an instance of sub graph
isomorphism so this is a very useful
thing to be able to do
and to understand is is the statement of
his result the one buzzword is
quasi-polynomial time and you can ask
Wolfram Alpha about that
so all quasi no quasi-polynomial time
means is that it means that if you have
a graph with n nodes that the runtime of
the algorithm is comparable to n raised
to well not a constant that would be
polynomial but to a power that grows
slowly that's the idea and the algorithm
he introduced quasi-polynomial time
algorithms is vastly more efficient than
what was known before the best previous
algorithm which has had the record for
30 years was due to a professor emeritus
at the University of Oregon named Eugene
Lux and so last year he improved the the
bound and this is this is this is really
a big result in computational complexity
theory and I'll explain why so well
let's just say in practice the best
known isomorphism testing algorithm is
Nauti which is inside Mathematica sadly
it's not implemented fully generalized
fine graph isomorphism function isn't
isn't there so it doesn't work on say
multigraphs
but I would refer you to I graph so I
graph is one of the most complete
open-source grafton affiliation
libraries and it can do this and there's
a there's a beautiful library link code
that interfaces with it supports multi
graph isomorphism testing directly
motifs minimum feedback arc sets a
random rewriting all this stuff it's
really good so what it is what did his
result do well it didn't prove that
isomorphism is in
is in P but it did you could say it it
put GI in the greater metropolitan area
of P so and P is just the set of
problems that can be solved efficiently
I'm getting a pop up here I'm kind of
cool so the you know P percent key right
it's big on cell problem and ass are all
problems in NP complete
do they have polynomial time algorithms
it doesn't really have ramifications for
it but it is really interesting if you
know about these things it could
disprove the exponential time hypothesis
and some other other interesting things
in approximation theory or in
approximation theory but I'll leave you
to the details because it would take it
takes a long time it's really heavy so
rather than talk about that I want to
talk about how we built his lecture
material so the first thing you'd want
to do when setting up tours for your
your deck for going around the world
giving these talks is you want to have
interactivity right so you're an
academic you have Beamer you want to
export frames and import the resident as
an animation so the obvious first thing
to do so generate animation showing how
various embeddings transform and
translate between one another and you
can do that really simply in Mathematica
and it's fun so for instance a papist
graph what you want to do is you want to
generate all these frames you want to do
it in parallel and you want to do it
with with you know internal bags and do
it in a resumable way with local symbols
so that because things are gonna crash a
lot and the frame rates are kind of
crappy but you can improve them no don't
use lists animate this is uh this is
trouble many times if you try to
import/export gifts you you will crash
the kernel so you can enhance them with
a little bit of dynamic trickery and you
can make them as smooth you can make
them upwards of you know 50 frames 60
frames a second
and that's lovely but when you have many
of them then it's not lovely then
everything comes to a grinding halt and
the same for large graphs let's see him
so for two it can handle it
for anything more than two basically the
front end just grinds to a halt so
that's an issue so it's gonna kill that
and the same thing for large graphs
everything just grinds to a halt so this
brings me to the main point the main
thrust of the talk which is how do you
deploy interactive infographics that are
beautiful and world-class well you need
to go beyond Mathematica to interface
with third-party libraries in various
languages and this is just a slide about
all the issues I drink so I tried the
first thing I tried it was using using
the cloud and there's there's there's
there's issues with stability and frame
rates there but what you can do is you
can use for these Mathematica symbols
you can use these open source solutions
so for graph you you can use something
called Sigma for graphics use d3 for
graphics 3d you want to use 3GS and for
cloud deploy instead of that you can
wrap everything up in it into a node
server and deploy it with react native
and so I'm going to show you demos of
all these things
[Music]
yeah unless you want to print into a PDF
which probably won't work or save it as
HTML with tooltips which won't work or
what have you so the first example is
using Sigma so you can get frame rates
that are insane so basically I exported
the entire graph data inventory of all
of all graphs and they're all running
smoothly in a single webpage that you
can open up on a browser so Sigma is a
wonderful library
it's a plug-and-play you know it's very
easy to draw force directed graphs it
has a forced to atlas algorithm like the
one in Jeffie which is another great
tool for doing graph stuff it's
significantly faster than d3 especially
with the if you use WebGL so it's fun to
look at so the next example was I wanted
to to take basically any any any 3d
graphics 2d graphics and graph objects
and basically transpile them right so
rewrite the source in a different
language maintaining all of the graphics
properties of these objects and the
dynamics and you can actually do it and
it's not that hard and you can get
results that are just just really super
smooth because the JavaScript can can go
down to bare metal now with opengl so
you can achieve speeds of interactivity
that are way beyond anything possible in
a CDF
yes
yes well so that's what I did and I'm
putting it on get github get labs and
everything no you know absolutely but it
already does it right with the API as
you can generate JavaScript to do stuff
but javascript has limitations and I
just wanted to show you something so
basically if you want to do something a
little bit more complicated and you want
to use some hardcore graph algorithms
you might hit some malls so for instance
this is another beautiful demonstration
I think is this lovely by Stan Wagon so
what this this looks for Hamiltonian
paths basically you start on a black and
you end on a white and hitting every
cell in between and in this example he's
using some powerful graph algorithms or
it might just be caching but you got the
point you could be using these graph
algorithms that aren't necessarily when
I rewrote it in Java Script available
now there is a what is it called less
power
I forget what the actual name of it is
but there's some guy who has a quote
that says anything that will that can be
written in JavaScript will be and it
might be for for Mathematica there might
be true I don't know but you can see
look how slow it is too it's going as
computing what millions of these paths
every second but it's not doing it in a
smart way right if I had access to some
of the higher-level operators in
Mathematica I could do this much faster
and being able to export these things we
great and that's why I'm so excited
about the LVM project that was like
always my five-year hope for Mathematica
and it seems like it's coming to
fruition and Tom Whitcomb Jones promised
me that you know graph will be there
that's one of the compilable objects
which would be really really cool
and the final example that I have here
yes
[Music]
right yeah yeah and and the original
hope was you know would Luke Bartlett I
mean we tried to do in script him you
know what that path of really compiling
the front edge JavaScript and it just
failed with I didn't think it should and
it's possible to do so let the last
librarian that I want to talk about is
three J s and you mention CDF but really
a plug-in is never gonna work
right no one will actually use five
hundred megabit plugins so so this is a
dead end
but yeah so 3GS what is it
well it's a way to export I've written a
way to export graphic primitives into a
WebGL wrapper written in JavaScript does
it look like well I had a really sexy
demo but I'm not gonna be able to show
it to you because version 11.10 networks
so that suffice to say I had this
beautiful demo where you take leanette
google net and you visualize what the
the outputs are of each neuron and you
can dynamically draw something like a
character it's trained on like m missed
it'll show you it'll propagate through
and i'll show you the the neural
responses from all the layers so I
exported it you can export any net graph
into into adjacent object and then you
can use things like synapse J s or any
of their cognate running on JavaScript
library and many of which exist was
written by Carpathia and you can and try
it so let's see what does one look like
well here
input field as we zoom through you can
actually inspect every single connection
every single computation in the entire
network and this is all running at you
know super high frame rates and it's
just super fun to play with and you know
so this is really the future I think for
all deployments the future is in CDF the
future isn't necessarily a private cloud
although I'm excited to see what that
can be but really I want to get back to
Mathematica strength is a prototyping
language and if we build in links from
the kernel to to external things like
Python like Sigma like JavaScript like
node box like defi like nginx if we
could serve web pages for real somehow
this is my so this is sort of like
war-cry and feature request please make
exporting code easy and that's in
process so I just wanted to give a
summary because I only have a minute
left so I give some examples and
hopefully they motivate you to think of
what's possible in terms of deploying
beautiful visuals from Mathematica to
the web that's what I'm doing for lacy
and yeah so that's sort of the summary
right we need javascript integration and
or enhanced Explorer ability for pieces
of code so thank you for listening I
have the packages that I use for
instance like to view video in
Mathematica and other things I'll be
releasing all of them and if you're
interested in computer vision and if you
come talk to me and I can get you an API
key so you can use dinner's tech but
that's everything so thank you very much
you